packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on take it
easy because it's time for my ultimate
slow cooking
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chess Arsenal not only is it easy
it's also an incredible way to transform
meat into mouth-waterly melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it Cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there and as the short rib Cooks
it sticks to that bone the bone implants
flavor and the meat just sort of melts
Cooks slowly gives it that nice level
intensity slice alongside the bone stray
down and see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates I'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
seasoned beef short ribs beautifully
olive oil in both of the top we'll start
coloring that in
[Music]
it's really important to give the big
short ribs a really nice Sear
if you didn't Brown the meat off it goes
in the oven and it looks like boiled
meat so you really want that nice dark
Rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the source stir in a
heap teaspoon of tomato puree I'm just
hitting the bottom of the pan
without tomato puree
and we call it cooking out that smell
the puree otherwise it just goes in
there raw and it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this Burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark Rich intensity
look at my garlic that is just gonna
sweeten everything up incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
packing all that flavor as the beef ribs
slow cook cover them so they braise from
the bottom and steam from the top into
the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
and she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
I want nice thick lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
these are delicious Chestnut mushrooms
I'm not going to slice them
just going to cut them in half
look at the color on those loud ones now
all the white raw fat have disappeared
the larvans have shrunk right down and
all we've got there now is the proper
bacon mushrooms in
beautifully so the mushrooms get
seasoned from the bacon I'm pan frying
these separately to the beef so they're
main crisp another different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now this is like Christmas day for me
when you unwrap that fall wait to see
what's underneath it
[Music]
hmm
wow
smell
incredible
lift
place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic Rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
we're all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing flavor
scrape all that off the sieve
nice
then just start
saving all that lovely braising liquor
whoa
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on your bacon and your mushrooms
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms I'm
telling you they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley on that freshness over
those amazing ribs incredible never ever
be embarrassed about going to your
Butcher and asking for cheap Cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs with bacon and mushrooms
mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients
I use Chestnut mushrooms with the beef
short ribs because all of their firm
texture and nutty taste but there's a
huge range of other mushrooms that are
great for slow cooked dishes
and when it comes to buying them there's
one expert green grocer who's a Fountain
of Knowledge Burma Marcus Fred Foster
started off on the dead store in primary
coat really you had a salad stalk with
over 20 years of experience you could
actually write his own mushroom
encyclopedia
mushrooms as soon as you pick them the
moisture starts coming out of them so
you need to buy them when they're fresh
certain products you smell for flavor
and they tend to be fruits mushrooms
don't smell nice at all they smell kind
of metallic really
so you have to use your eyes as you
guide of what you buy with mushrooms
really really important wild mushrooms
are literally grown wild in the forests
they're just quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom
a fantastic products so hard to find in
the world it's almost got an apricot
type of flavor earthy Woody and of
course as you cook it the flavor
increases for extra flavor and texture
highly prized morels are ideal when
added to slow cooked stews and
casseroles as are the trumpet de lemur
which have a deliciously rich flavor
another wild type to try is the
chanterelle its subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't don't use water
never use water with mushrooms it
deteriorates the mushroom rapidly oyster
mushrooms are very meaty mushroom just a
lovely silky smooth flavor really nice
how do you tell whether it's fresh those
gills are bright never cut a noise the
mushroom always tear it look at the
whiteness of that beautiful that would
be great if it was old although also
found wild oyster mushrooms are more
commonly cultivated along with similar
type the Enoki their delicate taste is
grain salads and soups
finally Fred saved the best until last
and of course the Pinnacle is the
Truffle they are really really short
after the smell is so intense that smell
it's it's hard to describe because it's
such a unique smell the more expensive
the Truffle the more intense the smell
so that's why you use such a small
amount on a dish it's amazing the way
they get these they used to use pigs of
course they don't do that anymore they
use Dog Steel because the pig juice to
eat them all this magical tasting fungi
is by weight one of the most expensive
Foods in the world it's phenomenal
eating raw shaved over pasta or risottos
or drizzle of truffle all Turns Slow
cooked stews into something out of this
world people are actually scared of
mushrooms aren't they so it's amazing
really they shouldn't be because take
away the fear and just close your eyes
and taste them they're just amazing
they're they are amazing
[Music]
cooking all the ingredients in one dish
helps to lock in taste and get great
flavors working together here are three
recipes that turn simple ingredients
into amazing dishes
first up a fantastically aromatic
melt-in-the-mouth treat pork neck curry
with mango salsa
[Music]
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
Cafe Lime Leaf to a pestle and mortar
next put in aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander
pinch of salt black pepper
[Music]
and Bash it into a rough paste
finally add olive oil to loosen and your
paste is done now onto the pork leg add
a lug of olive oil to a hot pan and
brown the diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor
remove and in the same pan cook sliced
onions until Brown around the edges
at the curry paste and Fry to release
all the intense flavors
then put the pork back in along with the
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar
more kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and
fish sauce to taste
then simply simmer for an hour
[Music]
slow cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful served with
fresh mango salsa pork neck Curry
foreign
recipe is
incredible spicy Szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinade the thighs with soy sauce
and shouting wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry
chicken thighs do a lot of work so they
need more cooking but cook properly
they're moist and they're the tastiest
part of the bird next add rice vinegar
water then season and leave to marinade
for up to two hours
then chop garlic
chili and Ginger
add olive oil to a hot pan and fry it
will softened add Szechuan peppercorns
and orange zest
next add the marinated chicken thighs
along with a marinade
and throw in a pinch of sugar and Fry
the chicken into as lovely and brown and
the sauce is deliciously thick
[Music]
finish with chopped spring onions add
lug of soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free Wonder
[Music]
my final slow cooked dish that
transforms simple ingredients into
Unforgettable food is simple beef
brisket
[Music]
start by seizing the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the breast
it's inexpensive but it's fit for raw
tea with long slow cooking
place it into hot casserole dish with a
little olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns
aromatic cloves and freshly ground
nutmeg
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cook low and slow the results are
amazing tender melt-in-the-mouth meat
fantastic with roast potatoes or in
sandwiches with lots of mustard but I
like it best with Tangy Piccadilly
in the oven in under 10 minutes then all
you have to do is sit back and wait so
easy and absolutely delicious what's not
to love about my succulent beef brisket
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on soon I'll
be teaching you a wonderful slow cooked
dessert and look at the color on them
these smell
incredible
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
[Applause]
foreign
starting with how to cook duck breasts
perfectly the slow way
duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy first oven on 200 degrees
and then
salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat
nonstick pan no oil but start the duck
breasts in the pan cold
skin side down it feels and sounds a
little bit weird but if we put them into
a cold pan and turn the heat up
gradually it starts to release the fat
if we put them into a hot pan
it seals them in and the fat stays in
there we want to render that fat down 90
of that duck breast will be cooked on
its skin keeps the duck nice and moist
but more importantly it stays crispy
once the fat comes out turn the duck
over
nice high hot heat
seal the duck now they're going in the
oven skin side down 200 six to eight
minutes
if your Pan's got a plastic handle it
then transfer the duck breast onto a
tray but make sure you put the tray into
the oven to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness Runs Out just quickly
turn it over
push your fingers in there and it's
slightly resistant but still quite
bouncy and that confirms they're quite
pink in the center but the important
part now is leaving that to rest let
them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fats and there you
go next time you start taking potatoes
you just take them to a completely
different level now slicing the duck
just slice it at an angle not too thin
if you're slightly thinner it goes cold
quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top
and a beautiful Clump roasted dark all
the white fat gone nice crispy skin and
absolutely delicious
another slow cooking tip is when slow
cooking stews and casseroles fat will
rise to the surface to get rid of any
excess oils my tip is to remove them
with kitchen paper before serving
this also works brilliantly on gravies
and sauces
many great slow cook dishes start by
Browning the meat as the meat Cooks lots
of flavors get stuck to the pan to get
it into your sauce deglaze with wine
stock or vinegar
never add soft herbs at the beginning of
slow cooking they're all too delicate
the tip is to add them at the end for
that Hill fresh flavor and vibrant color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry skin side down to keep it
crispy
and always lay the Footers away from you
when adding to the pan to prevent hot
oil from splashing towards you
[Music]
foreign
cooking isn't exclusive to just Savory
dishes it's a clever way to transform
fruit into wonderful desserts giving
them an amazing sticky Jammy intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time
Indulgence and bursting with flavor
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in a rows
take some Rosemary and just peel that
down look at that really nice fragrant
stem get your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of Blossom
with vinegar leave them to sit there for
five minutes they sort of marinate I
know it sounds odd to use vinegar in
your dessert but trust me it gives the
dish a fantastic sweet and sour taste
I'm going to make a really nice caramel
four or five tablespoons of sugar now
flatten that out and get it nice and
even when the sugar is even caramel
Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center it's bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas not with butter in
there
gently whisk in
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a lug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
a fix and sort of place them in gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and Balsam and vinegar
so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the camel
delicious so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now that's the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
I'm gonna finish that now
it seems zest
and then
some little nibbed hormones
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
cookery course crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stag your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking now it's time to
settle down and enjoy some slow cooked
favorites
one of the brilliant things about slow
cooking is there's often very little
preparation required and it's the oven
that does all the work
my first recipe is packed with strong
confident flavors and with the oven
taking the strain is a pleasure to make
[Music]
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work brilliantly well so
don't be precious this is gutsy cooking
at its absolute best
these are lamb breasts are beautiful
cheap cuts and they're sort of tucked
alongside the rib they've been boned out
the skin has been taken off I'm going to
roll them stuff them and braise them
braising simply means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat divinely
tender now open them up and give them a
really good seasoning season them both
sides inside and out really important it
doesn't look like a real weighty dense
cup of meat but once it's beautifully
slow braised it's just like melting lamb
it's incredible I'm going to season the
breasts with some dried oregano
put a heat in there some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
[Applause]
amazing
salted anchorries in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb so the
balance of flavors work beautifully
now pull it down towards you and roll
that nice and tightly
that's what I'm looking for
a string
just need to tie them three times one at
each end and one in the middle
I fell in love with this dish years ago
when I first started working in Paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
Pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
look at that oil nice and hot
lemon
it's really important to get it's a nice
color on there whilst they're Browning
slice The Onion
the Lamb's gonna be cooking for two and
a half hours so don't slice the onions
too thinly otherwise it'll burn garlic
and leave whole got a color on them look
at that beautiful
take them out onions in and garlic
straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans why of all the
goodness isn't that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
argano nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there and I'll
do the onions what I did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fry them off
get them exploding to the bottom of the
pan they get nice and crispy next my
black olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
a rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now where are our tomatoes
puncher
those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breasts back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
lid on
into the oven 170. two two and a half
hours and forget about it
whoa
beautiful
all that was reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
it's kept its color look at that that's
braised beautifully
very carefully
little bits there it's nice off pull off
the little bits of string
this is why I get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there but that is a
very cheap cut of meat on salivating I
love this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
and amazing
Rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
hit it on
it looks incredible
that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap Cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]
slow cooking is a fantastic way to
develop delicious deep flavors here are
three of my easy one pot wonders minimum
preparation long cook and an amazing
wonderful taste
first up easy ballito misto a classic
Italian mixed meat dish
[Music]
I'm starting with some Italian fennel
sausages
[Music]
fry them until colored making sure all
sides are nicely browned
set them aside then slice chorizo a
spicy Spanish sausage with a wonderful
Smoky taste and Fries so releases all
its incredible flavor
[Music]
next chop carrots
celery garlic and add to the same pan
this keeps in all the flavor
stirring the pre-lentals these are
excellent for slow cooked dishes because
they retain their firm texture and shape
next add a bay leaf and some fresh thyme
sprigs
then the sausages go back in along with
chicken stock
simmer until the lentils are tender then
seasoned to taste
[Music]
finally sprinkle with chopped parsley
and serve simple to prepare a cinch to
make and packed full of delicious hearty
flavors my Twist on an Italian classic
magnificent easy ballito misto
[Music]
foreign
dish is slow cooked aubergine
dice the aubergine and fry in hot olive
oil until colors on all sides
then add a finely sliced onion and
chopped garlic
cook until tender
cooked butter beans and pomegranate
molasses which is a sweet thick and
glossy Tangy reduction of pomegranate
juice
season
[Music]
next add a can of chopped tomatoes
bring to a simmer and cook until the
aubergine has a gloriously soft and
silky texture
stir through top mint pile onto toasted
bread and finally for a lovely salty
Tang crumble over some creamy feta
cheese
preparation but slow cook for maximum
flavor aubergines like you've never
tasted before
one more dish that uses time to
transform a humble ingredient is perfect
slow cooked beef
foreign
[Music]
the beef Shin in hot oil seasoning as
you go
it's a very economical cut of beef as it
slow Cooks it also makes the most
delicious gravy as the marrow thickens
and flavors the sauce
[Music]
the same pan saute chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots
sliced celery peeled and chopped ginger
and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
[Music]
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine
and the juice of an orange this deglazes
the pan adding incredible depth of
flavor
pour in chicken stock season and simmer
for an hour and 20 minutes
brilliant finish with gremolata a dry
Italian salsa made with chopped herbs
simply chop parsley and garlic together
and mix in the zest of an orange or
lemon
when the beef is cooked Rich anxious and
beautifully tender scatter over the
lovely fresh gremolata
simple satisfying and crammed full of
wonderful taste and textures delicious
fast to prepare cheap and easy to make
slow cooked to Perfection three amazing
dishes I guarantee you'll make time and
time again
[Music]
this is my Essential guide to kitchen
equipment everything you need to know
about the basic kit that will get you
cooking fantastic food
casserole dish
absolutely essential when it comes to
good home cooking why so versatile the
beauty of this thing is the fact that
you can actually use it on the hob or
start it on the hob and finish it in the
oven more importantly
cast iron it conducts the heat so you
can have the gas on absolute minimal or
the oven down to its absolute lowest
setting and the thing will just cook
naturally casserole dishes are
surprisingly versatile and a great
investment you only need one and if you
look after it it'll last you a lifetime
brilliant for one pot wonders welcome
back to my ultimate cookery course
I'm teaching you my slow cooked
favorites
next up my guide to getting the best
value from your butchers one of the
biggest bills in the kitchen is going to
be for meat so it's crucial you keep
costs down but that doesn't mean
sacrificing flavor especially when you
use some slow cooking magic to get the
best from cheap cuts to get value for
money it always pays to ask an expert
and fifth generation award-winning
Master butcher Danny lidgate is a man in
the know one of the great things about
going to a butcher is they're going to
have more Cuts available than most
supermarkets so you're going to see
things that people don't know about so
one example might be the beef ribs a
great product for slow cooking the oven
basically cooking on the bone you're
going to get more flavors from the bone
there's some really nice pieces of Juicy
meat it's only used for mince in the
past now people are using it for
braising or slow braising or even
barbecuing it with some really nice
marinades the oxtail are less popular
now than maybe they used to be small
little mussels make up the tail once
that's slow cooked they all fall apart
really tender juicy Meats also oxtail is
Sublime en stews curries and soups
another great cheap cut for slow cooking
is one you saw me using earlier Lamb's
breast
[Music]
is one of the least expensive cuts of
lamb and it's also delicious slow
roasted or stewed here we have the shin
of beef
you can see
in the sheds made up of lots of little
different mussels these are always
moving always doing work so slow cooking
will give the best end results it's
going to have fashion a little bit but
it should be enjoyed by everybody it's a
fantastic piece of meat here we have
some ox cheeks and when they're trimmed
you end up with a really lean piece of
meat obviously with the cheek the cow's
always eating munching on grass this
means I need a lot of cooking but
essentially it's a really nice healthy
lean piece of meat with fantastic
flavors
oxchicks also make an incredible ravioli
or Ragu and if you're a pork lover why
not try pork neck it's a succulent
alternative for a slow Sunday roast here
we have a muscle from the shoulder it's
called feather blades
the reason it's called feather blade is
because when it's cut
each piece looks like a feather the
gristle tends to be slow cooked and the
more it's cooked we'll turn gelatinous
giving a lovely jelly and juicy liquid
to the meat fantastic for casserole pies
and stews there are so many cheaper cuts
which are brilliant for home cooking
it's important with all these forgotten
cuts to find out how to cook them don't
be scared of them they're really
economic but full of flavor and the end
result is fantastic meal
as a chef one of the biggest kicks I get
is taking an ingredient that doesn't
cost much and turning into something
that looks and tastes like a million
bucks
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish fit to Grace any
table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife bring the pork
belly towards you so you're over it
you've got all that pressure and weight
using the tip of the knife I'm just sort
of nicking it and go across the pork
belly long strokes with a knife take
your time turn it 180 this time what
we're doing is just sort of cutting
those nice little sort of diamonds but
as that starts roasting on top it starts
getting nice and crispy
take your handfuls of salt and just sort
of rub it in bend it over and then all
those cracks really helps to get a nice
crisp crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
I'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
fennel in
I like the nice strong aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds delicious
star anise in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear the top of that fat that locks
in all that amazing flavor then I'm
gonna flip it over and get it nice and
crispy
and then on fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can just smell that light fragrance
and the fennel
allow the wine to Bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol is burnt off time to
have the stock NOW the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there will be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and braises at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never go up
to temperature
smells incredible
slow roasted pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock has
evaporated
put that onto the board it looks
stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavor packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat take a couple of slices of
bread it's like a perfect sponge because
you just lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that fat if you want
the perfect fried bread trust me stick
that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife
you can hear that
oh
that
is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy belly of pork what an
amazing way to cook a very cheap cut of
meat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
kitchen tips
first how to make a fantastic chicken
stock a classic slow cook recipe that
gets amazing flavor from simple
ingredients
chicken stock
ingredient to good cooking it trans
forms sources it's a fantastic base for
Soups and more importantly it's so easy
to do a little bit of love and care at
the beginning and it Cooks itself right
step one chicken carcass into a pie
sided pan an onion
does need to be finely chopped the
vegetables flavor the stock
onion in
then from there cut your leek into nice
big solid chunks roughly
same size as the onion
silver vegetables cook at the same time
and then add carrots
celery and garlic
and then a nice
sprig of thyme that helps to really give
depth of flavor to the chicken stock a
couple of Baileys
and some fresh parsley
and then peppercorns pan and just
lightly crush them
and a little pinch of salt
and now just cover the vegetables and
the carcass with cold water
just cover the chicken and the
vegetables
bring it up to the ball as quick as you
can
now as it comes to the boil a really
nice skin take the base of a ladle and
swirl that around that pushes all the
grease and the impurities to the side of
the pan then get your Ladle and just
tilt it
if you don't skim all that off the stock
becomes very cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
then it needs to cook for three four
hours at a time this is one chicken
carcass let that boil away gently for 30
to 40 minutes maximum
we're gonna pass it off
let's take a sieve
place that over
the pan
and then just
pour that in
it smells amazing it's aromatic
color it's absolutely beautiful
and there you have
the most amazing stock
when you need to season meat in flour a
great tip is to place it in a plastic
bag to dust it evenly using flour also
helps the sauce to get nice and thick
during cooking
we're Browning meat fry in small batches
don't crowd the pan otherwise it won't
sear or color properly
when slow roasting meat line the bottom
of the roasting tray with chunky
vegetables like onions fennel and
carrots they act as a trivet to keep the
meat from boiling in its own juices plus
the veg can be the base for your gravy
later on
after slow cooking baked on residue can
be tough to remove but if you boil water
in the pan it will dissolve and break
down then simply pour out and wash with
soap and water
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the App Store